thank you so much for joining
oh good I have my questions
woof
all right so it's quite a bright light
you have here it's and it's a little
chilly I know you guys were worried a
little bit about yeah
um I also like to welcome our Twitter
audience who's watching now live so
I've called you both here to talk about
um really a a a big problem it's really
it's a global crisis at this point and
I'm gonna I'm gonna bring it up here
see if I can get this here all right
props yeah
all right so terrifying it is it is
quite a problem
um we're going to start with you jaws
actually you know what they gave me a
pointer as well you're not going to hit
me with that oh yes I know it depends on
the answer it depends on the answer so
what do you what do you see when you
look at that C2 really cool connectors
yeah kind of the two most popular
connectors in the world I think right
now okay yeah
uh Craig I know you're a software guy
but what do you see I gotta really agree
with Jaws on this one these are great
connectors two great connectors okay I
see a little bit of a mess one of them
has a much better name though don't you
think lightning yes lightning so yes one
name by marketing people one name by
engineers hey
um I
and so I'll tell you right so this
charges the iPhone I'm not sure you guys
know that this charges the iPhone now
this charges the mac and iPad and
various other products around the world
and so that's creating a little bit of
friction in fact the EU has approved
legislation to create a common charger
in fact they said in a press release
yesterday in 2024 a USBC Port will
become mandatory for a whole range of
electronic devices such as mobile phones
tablets and headphones
I think that includes you guys
is Apple moving to USBC
well maybe I can step back a little bit
you may uh
you probably heard me say for years that
I
don't mind governments telling us what
they want to accomplish but usually
we've got some pretty smart Engineers to
figure out the best ways to accomplish
them technically and
an example of that that I love to give
is for years and years mobile phones had
to satisfy a hearing aid compatibility
spec
very prescriptively described by you
know regulation that said here's what
you have to do to be compatible with
hearing aids the problem is it didn't
work
but all of us had to do it
and so we came up with a new way of
doing hearing aids made for iPhone uh
hearing aids actually made an industry
standard that actually worked
you know so what we were accomplishing
is what the government wanted was to
have hearing impaired people be able to
use phones but we did in a way that
worked better
and you know we've been in an argument
over this one for well over 10 years
and over 10 years ago the push
from the EU look they're well-meaning I
get you know I get the fact that they
want to accomplish some good things
what's to do micro USB
and standardized as a micro USB if we
have standardized micro USB that chart
doesn't exist
right neither of those happen and so we
have been in this little bit of a
disagreement and but part of what of
course they wanted to accomplish is why
should people have all these different
power adapters so we got to what we
think was a better place right which is
power adapters that had detachable
cables you know all of them usb-a or
USBC and largely moving USBC but you
choose the cable you know that was
appropriate for your device uh whether
that's one of ours or somebody else's
and what that allowed you to do is have
over a billion people
it's not a small number of people that
have that connector on the left right to
be able to use what they have already
and not have to be disrupted by that and
cause a bunch of E-Waste as well I mean
because what are you going to do with
these cables over time if they're no
longer useful and again billions of them
right because everybody's more and more
cable and so we preferred that path uh
governments you don't get to do what
they're going to do and obviously we'll
have to comply we have no choice as as
we do around the world to comply to
local laws but you know we think the
approach would have been better
environmentally and better for our
customers to to not have a government be
that prescriptive what's so good about
lightning that you're so you seem very
sad to see it go well it's been a great
connector and over a billion people have
it already have the cables have what
they need have all the infrastructure in
their homes have speakers that work with
it all kinds of you know an ecosystem
that works with it and
for most iPhone customers it's primarily
about charging not all it's primarily
about charging lightning charges pretty
well
yeah
okay all right I guess
how soon might we see it
USBC well again the the Europeans are
the ones dictating timing for European
customers and you know you know they're
but you wouldn't just probably change it
in one area oh Joanna you're trying to
get me to predict the future or at least
or at least disclose it and you know me
better than that all right all right
we'll move on to another part of the
iPhone or in general the iPhone marks 15
years of the iPhone and
um the pace of innovation has obviously
slowed it's in your visual aid I'm
losing my visual aid it's okay
there will be fantastic yeah this isn't
an apple style presentation but there
will be more okay no track suits no no
crazy hair blowing things we don't have
that
um
back to the iPhone
um 15 years
very rapid pace of innovation at first
first five to seven years and now it
feels like things have have slowed a
little bit and some people say phones
have become boring right wow I think
that's other people's phones yeah
and I agree with that
ours are quite exciting
two questions one why does there need to
be
need to be wow well first of all right
you can answer these two okay I'd love
to
oh Joanna I mean I wouldn't have loved
to answer that last one but Jaws did
wonderful one of the things that I love
and you probably heard my story from all
the way back to the very first iPhone
when we you know which didn't launch
till sixth in the in the afternoon that
day and yet there was a people that
camped out all night for it people are
still in lines waiting for new iPhones
every year they're excited by what we do
we leave a lot of innovation including
in software and Hardware because as you
know we're the guys that put it all
together people are very excited by the
new iPhones Dynamic Island the things we
have 48 megapixel camera all the things
we did with the the iPhone 14 and iPhone
14 pro I think it's people very excited
so again I can't speak for these boring
phones you're talking about but like I
said those sound like somebody else's
yeah and I just say that you said why
every year uh I think we always have a a
ton of stuff that I mean we we've got to
get it out I mean we've been working on
it for years and years there's a
pipeline of things that we feel are
really going to positively impact our
customers if we can take a better
picture
that's a year of capturing maybe your
young family with a better picture and I
think that's meaningful and every year
we work to harness
the power the best sensors we can create
the best silicon the best computational
photography pipeline we can manage I
think these matter to a lot of people
you don't have to buy a phone a new one
every year but someone is going to
decide they want the best camera they
can get that those capabilities are
really compelling and so we want to give
them that option makes sense when well
you mentioned silicon I think we're so
used to so many of Apple's best products
being new things we can see the iPod the
iPhone iPad
seems like one of your biggest
Innovations in the last I would say five
years has been your own silicon in Max
tell me about why you made that decision
why did why did you make the decision to
leave Intel
and say we need to go at this on our own
well I mean the story of our silicon is
you know goes back further than our
transition to Apple silicon on the Mac
right this uh this journey started with
the iPhone and Apple uh has always
deeply believed in controlling the
technology that's most Central to
delivering the user experience for our
products and there's no doubt when it
came to building the best phone possible
that the application processor which
integrates all the functionality it's
not just a CPU it's not even just a
graphics processor it's a media pipeline
it's an ISP it's now it's about
artificial intelligence and a neural
engine I mean fundamental aspects of
building the capab the experience of
iPhone are tied up in that silicon and
of course in a mobile phone it also
drives the kind of industrial design you
can manage when it comes to things like
power efficiency so
controlling that was fundamental to
building the right product and our team
really focused for years and years on
the right problem that I think a lot of
the industry was ignoring which was
power per watt efficiency not just about
Peak Performance at any any power level
but performance per watt and year in
year out getting better and better at
that and
we could chart out where that was going
and where that was intersecting with
what our other products needed high-end
iPads and eventually Max and
for those of us that had had the luxury
for years on being able to spec out the
experience for our customers going from
Silicon to the hardware to the software
that was going to run on it and being
able to do that with our in-house
silicon when it came to iPhones and
iPads and having to go through what we
had to go with really making a lot of
really unfortunate compromises when it
came to Silicon we didn't control on the
Mac we were really eager to get there
when those performance lines crossed and
I think I mean you you probably remember
when that happened uh we said at the
time it vastly exceeded our expectations
which is a kind of crazy thing when you
go to build something you say I think
it's going to be this good and then we
start running the tests and we put all
the pieces together and we're saying I
mean people are coming in going my God
you you wouldn't believe the numbers
were getting you would and which is
crazy because we're pretty good at
estimating these things but overshot and
and I think in in all respects our users
have felt like it is it has exceeded all
of our expectations and it is a
wonderful place to be yeah and I think
you have people who never really thought
much about processors right never really
thought about Intel inside and now has a
they have different experience on the
Mac and so you know when we brought out
that M1 I mean people had a hard time
believing what we were saying up on
stage I think a lot of you journalists
right how can it be that much faster and
give you this much more battery life
because as Craig said no one had really
done that equation right where they
focused on the power per watt
but every single journalist that
reviewed it right every single you know
tester that tested it found the same
conclusion right that it was unlike
anything they'd ever seen faster and yet
incredible battery life and this is what
we've been experiencing iPhone for years
I mean look you're in a stock this year
we still you know have such an advantage
that our competition is trying to catch
up with where we were with iPhone 11 you
know from a performance standpoint and
we're at iPhone 14 and using less power
than they're using them and it's
experience thing too Beyond just battery
life and raw performance I think you
pointed out when we came out with it the
fans or the lack of fans I mean how long
were we all cursed by just that that
buzzing uh it is it is Serenity to have
be able to use your computer and not
hear it right and that that took an
incredible feat of silicon engineering
is it too quiet now I'm sorry it's too
quiet it's alone with your thoughts just
haunted if you can also make my kids a
little bit quieter it'll be great great
we're on that that's a good point
right it's the ISP it's the unified
memory and there's just so many
advantages to the architecture that
again is new to PCS so in a move to
privacy in a few minutes but I have a
few questions and we don't have a lot of
time so I want to do a rapid fire thing
here oh we like going slow no yeah yeah
the clock is running out but you get
five words to answer each of these
questions
is there a point system
um if you go over uh
no
okay will we ever see a touch screen on
the Mac
who's to say
okay
why isn't there a calculator app on the
iPad
who's to say
okay now we're up to six the same answer
[Laughter]
tons of them go to the App Store why
doesn't Apple have a calculator app on
the ice we do a handful of apps relative
to the 1.8 million hours you never
wanted to add something on your on your
iPad I use the third part I just want to
see you both violated the 10 word limit
I think it's time to move on why can't
Siri set two timers on my iPhone
who's to say
you can't keep saying who's to say you
know we'll ask you
you didn't establish the rules clearly
enough I did not
um how many iPad models do you have
right now
who's to say
all right we're moving on from this all
right you know what we'll do this one
but you can get more time in the words
of the iPad commercial girl
what is a computer
well that's the thing she doesn't need
to care it doesn't matter because it
does what she wants and yeah I'm really
getting nowhere
and I crowdsourced some of these
questions the people who are watching on
Twitter I'm sorry I'm sorry Twitter I'm
sorry all right
we're gonna move to privacy so back in
2021 You released app tracking
transparency or ATT and it gave users
more Choice over sharing their data with
other companies it was this
another prop tiny tiny pop-up right we
have these tiny pop-ups all coming up on
our phones right a big big business
impact right knocks billions in Revenue
off of companies like meta Google others
did you anticipate this domino effect
uh I'd say we we couldn't be sure uh I
think we were
truly just focused on doing the right
thing I mean our conversations were just
users we'd been working for so many
years to try to bring more transparency
and control to so many areas of
experience and years before we brought
uh intelligent tracking prevention to
Safari and so we we'd seen the problem
of tracking on the web and we'd been
able to counter it to in large part and
we felt the world of apps should be no
different that that users should have
the same level of protection or even
even better in the world of apps uh and
so the Privacy team that that is in my
organization we we set out to change it
and you know I think there was
uncertainty about what the short-term
impact would be I think we felt in the
long term
that quality advertising and privacy
could co-exist there would be Innovation
some of it from us some of it from
others uh but that Journey had to start
uh it was it was what we wanted for
ourselves and our friends and our family
we thought it was
people should have that level of control
and so that's the that's the road we
went down yeah it's a simple question
Joanna and it's just getting the users
say yeah that's okay I mean how many
times have you shopped for something and
all of a sudden you are now getting
emails from other you know shoe
companies when you buy shoes or you're
seeing you know web ads everywhere
sometimes that creeps people out and
sometimes it's not as simple as shoes
right and as you know data Brokers are
building profiles on you you know based
on what can be sent to them that you
have no idea so all we're saying is look
advertising is cool just get the user's
permission if you're going to send it to
other companies and I think that's the
part people miss right you you can
obviously if you interact with the
company there's an expectation that they
have some information on you the the
creepy part in the part that people
don't really didn't totally grok is no
they're selling you know all this
information and building those profiles
of you that you don't even know exists
you know they know everything about you
right and again for some people that's
cool you know but at least ask your
permission and I think this felt really
wrong to us because we knew
even people in the industry didn't
really understand the extent of what was
going on let alone the average user and
I mean ultimately
we all came to Apple to build these
products that we wanted to do good in
the world and the idea that these could
be used in a way that our customers
maybe didn't expect in a way that was
not in their interests uh
that they should have a choice and I I
think that was
in some ways a really simple decision
there's been this feeling though that
you know a little bit of the move has
been hypocritical as Apple
or there are reports that Apple wants to
move more into advertising is that any
part of the motivation is Apple have
well I should I should say first
Zero part of the motivation I can tell
you I mean I've heard
conspiracy theories
that are crazy and weird to read because
I personally was part of uh the uh
discussion to go down this road and none
of that this was driven by our privacy
team as part of a long agenda that you
could watch in Apple's business year
after year after year how we were
stepping up privacy Protections in area
after area this was our team going you
know we feel protecting apps consistent
with what we've done Safari makes sense
we brought this to business and just
said heads up everyone you know what
you're doing this year after your
privacy agenda here's what's coming that
is where this feature came from Full
Stop
and by the way again just to clarify
we're not against advertising and by the
way we're hearing by all the same rules
right we're not sending any of your
information you know to anybody without
your permission as a matter of fact we
don't set a period and we give you
options to even opt out of what we're
keeping within you need in your own app
in our own apps yeah that's right I I in
fact actually you mentioned not to tell
you about it's interesting that you have
this privacy roadmap obviously those of
us that watch all the the wwc Keynotes
we know that now to expect sort of the
Privacy section right
what is the reason for that I mean is
that does it help sell more phones are
people buying because there's privacy
it's well it's funny it's funny you say
that because
for many many years this this journey
for us on privacy and so we started with
with the origin of the of the the
company as a personal computer I mean
our sensibilities at Apple are you had
your computer you had your floppy disks
there was no Mainframe that had your
data you owned your data I mean this is
just so core to what sort of feels right
to us but if you go back to when we
created iPhone
we put all these Protections in place so
the app has to ask if they want to
access your photos they have to ask if
they want to use your camera you know
all of this was completely new to the
industry but something we felt really uh
strongly about and as as time went on
there was a lot of discussion that we
were in a uh not with an apple but
outside we're in post-privacy world and
isn't AI all about needing all the data
so and then does anyone actually care
and within Apple we're saying it doesn't
matter this is what we think is right
and again these are the products we want
for ourselves I you know for for my kids
I didn't want them using products that
uh where people were serious slurping up
their data sharing it all over the place
so we were constantly doing these things
that I think the rest of the industry
thought we were crazy this is surely
holding us back you could I'm sure you
could find articles in your your own
paper perhaps years ago yeah what is
that why what is Apple's problem like
why are they so obsessed with this stuff
and so it's it's just why child to me
now when people come oh Apple aren't you
just doing this because it's so hot like
what you know no we're doing it because
it's right and you know at the time we
said well maybe someday someone's going
to realize when they fully become aware
of how this being abused maybe they're
going to say Well thank goodness Apple
was doing something about this but that
has never been the reason we've done
anything in this area okay
um
I'm running out of time but
you guys have nothing else to do tonight
right we came here to see you really
yeah okay and go to the bar after well
hell yeah yeah okay all right
um you know speaking of we're talking a
little bit about ecosystem and Craig now
I want to read you back an email of
yours from 2013. you might you might
have read it before or written it before
uh it was to Apple's Eddie Q is a
colleague of yours and you said I'm
concerned that iMessage on Android would
simply serve to remove an obstacle to
iPhone families giving their kids
Android phones
whatever happened to iMessage on Android
I'm not aware of its shipping
yeah
you sent this email though I sent this
email you felt like maybe we shouldn't
release this product because other
people will buy Android phones
my feeling and I think F1 read the whole
the whole email was clear the back and
forth with Eddie was if
if we're going to enter a market and go
down the road a building an application
we have to be in it uh in a way that's
going to make a difference that we would
have a lot of customers that we would be
able to deliver great experiences this
comes at a real cost and my fear was we
weren't
in a position to do that and so if we
just shipped an app that really didn't
get critical mass on other platforms
what it would have accomplished is it
would have held us back in innovating in
all the ways we wanted to innovate in
messages on uh for our customers
and wouldn't really have accomplished
much at all in any other way and so
we just felt
you know pick pick where you can make a
difference pick where you're going to
invest and do it where where you'd make
a difference and this seemed like a
throwaway that wasn't going to serve uh
the world honestly
one of the big themes of the conference
and has been around the obviously the
macro environment uh and return to work
and so you know it kind of strikes me
every time I go to Apple's campus well
who wouldn't want to be at this campus
five days a week
um but you guys have returned to work a
couple days a week
um how are you and some it sounds like
some folks at Apple have they don't want
to get back to the office they do
there's this tension between some folks
how are you managing through that as you
manage well first of all I'll speak for
myself I think you probably know
I love going Apple party you know so
I've been going back you know I think
2020 we are mostly missed you know we
did some filming of our events you're
familiar with those uh but I started
coming back long before we were asked
and a bunch of people did there's always
going to be a spectrum of folks right I
think one of the things that were and
people are amazed to see is you get back
and you do remember the power of
collaboration uh people love to tell
their little anecdotes of things that
they were able to accomplish because
they were in a room together in front of
a whiteboard uh
you know there's a there's a a book uh
sorry to go here but uh golf in the
Kingdom right which is a famous kind of
Zen golf book uh and one of the things I
always remember for it it's what's
between the holes that counts and and
the reality is life is not just meeting
sometimes it's what's between the
meetings 100 that count right it's the
conversations you have sometimes they're
social nature and that's okay because
we're bonding we're building a culture
you know sometimes they're that let's
stay a little extra and talk on
whiteboard about something we can do
together
WebEx you know which we use you know
Zoom other people use just don't lend
themselves to that but they do have a
purpose right and they're pretty
efficient for getting meetings done so
what we try to do is a blend of both
right we have three days in the office
right two days that everybody's in the
same day Tuesday and Thursday there's
commonality Third Day the teams can
decide I think most teams have decided
on Wednesday but some are moving that
around uh and then the other two are do
it on you know on WebEx and I think it's
a nice blend you know of of learning new
tricks and by the way what are the
things that we've said it's a hybrid uh
you know I mean and it's it's and it's a
pilot right and that we'll see how it
goes and we'll figure out how we make
things better because that's what we do
we're Apple we're always trying to
figure out how to make things better uh
as you would expect this is one of those
areas as well we're better
and we're happier when we're together I
is that a song
we can write it we got to explain these
microphones we got the right mic we can
dance free
um you do look like Britney Spears yes
yeah it's been a real it's been a
lifelong yesterday
it's something I've been working on all
right but the the
I mean it's it's strange that as as we
were in the pandemic and we'd all talk
about
the the you know depression and the
Mental Health crisis and we talk about
how our kids were were devastated by the
lack of connection
and yet somehow we thought we weren't
affected by this that that all of us
wouldn't benefit from being connected
with the people with whom we're doing
the most important work of Our Lives I
think it's crazy and
when we've been back
we are so much more effective and we are
enlivened and invigorated and happy and
finding that space in between meetings
and making decisions and spotting
problems earlier and coming up with
better ideas and this has been
fundamental to Apple's way of being
forever I mean our our whole culture has
been about being in the same place
together Building Products in tight
interdisciplinary teams and that's
that's who we are and when you hear uh I
I mean I think it's an honestly it's a
big disservice that I when it with what
I read where people say Apple employees
don't want to come back what are they
referring to they're referring to
petition by like I don't know a tenth of
a percent of Apple employees of course
there's some people who
moved to Kansas and said this is where I
want to be sure is that Apple employees
it's an an Apple employee
um but I think a lot of us are um
thrilled to be able to engage with one
another and I think it's important
um does it also mean more face time with
your boss I was going to just quickly
ask what it's what it's like to work for
Tim Cook does he does he bother you guys
on iMessage
come to my office right now well he's
actually great for in-person meetings by
the way a lot of Snapchat though the
lenses he's heavy with the lenses
definitely likes in-person meetings and
I think we've some you know an
incredibly important dialogue together
and together as an executive team you
know yeah we've a lot of time together
we've always met together for hours
every week I mean that's a staple to to
our culture and of course Tim leads
those meetings
how's it work on the Apple car coming
the Apple card the little white one
um yeah but the car oh I'm sorry I
thought you said out the card because
Apple card's doing quite well uh I
suggest you all get one you know pays
your money back doesn't cost anything
really cool uh-huh how about the the
headset how's that work coming
airpods no that see nothing
airpods
spatial audio it's going to blow your
mind it is probably when you build it
into the headset right
um I'm gonna ask you the same question I
asked Evan Spiegel though um you have to
finish this sentence both of you the
metaverse is a word I'll never use
Craig the metaverse is
I'm good with that
um yeah you guys aren't going to tell me
anything about new products
um but I do you know what can end here
on
at Apple
you must at some point come to a sense
of this is an r d product this is a
project that's r d at what point does
something go from well I'd love you to
take me through the whole process but
how do you get from something that's r d
to something that's ready to ship
is there
a process of how you think about
what that is
well there's a lot of technology that we
work on for years you know and sometimes
they become enabling Technologies to
create other things you know a classic
example that is the multi-touch display
right we've worked on that for years
before there was an iPhone and as you
know and as we talked about you know
publicly we were applying that to a
different project and before we decided
to apply it to the what became the
iPhone so it's always hard to say that's
why sometimes it's hard to say even when
some projects start because what do you
mean because the Technologies may have
been something that we've been we've
been gestating for quite some time the
others
there are so many threads of exploration
in experiences we want to create in
fundamental technologies that could
enable those experiences some of them
are in the background percolating for
years and years because there's
something we know we want to get to but
the pieces aren't quite there and then
there are points where we think we can
start to put these pieces together and
we're building prototypes and we're
seeing what what might work but even
then
to get to the final product sometimes
that's involving yeah but we're going to
need the the following pieces of custom
silicon to make that happen and we're
going to need the following you know
camera system with these sensors and uh
that can be years and years of lead time
um and in the end when you look at a
great Apple product it involved
almost every discipline imaginable the
full the full breadth of the talent of
the company from from design to silicon
and everything in between and what's
I think so incredible about being part
of it at Apple is
none of us could do it without
all of us together that and that when we
decide there is an experience we want to
deliver there's a product that we want
to create it can be at that point
four years out five years out and
everybody is going to align and
everyone's going to make it happen and
uh we will knock through walls uh many
walls because we know we all depend on
each other to get it done and and I
think it's uh yeah it's just amazing to
be part of that group of talented people
with that passion to make it happen but
it's a long process it is one of those
if we can imagine it
we really feel like we could grade it
because of our ability to do you know
incredible world-class software and
class hardware and now world-class
Services all combined we think we can
create things that just it's it's hard
to create anywhere else
so you're imagining a car
she's so obsessed with that Apple card
yeah and it's already out yeah
oh I'll leave out this this last
question then Apple is still a computer
company right computers now are taking
so many different shapes and forms what
do you both wish your computers did
better
I think that's a trick to get us to tell
you what's coming in the future yeah
because it kind of goes if you follow
the logic we can imagine it we can
create it so if I can tell you what we
can imagine do something better we're
creating it it's a trick Joanna you must
work in marketing
that was beautiful Josh yeah
you're not going to answer no because
he'll be telling you the future because
again we
you look you can you can be
philosophical
no I couldn't no
okay well we're gonna end there but I
wanted to thank you guys so much for
coming and so I wanted to get you a
special present oh another prop yeah
another problem
these both are a bunch of cords see I
wanted to give you both I wanted to give
you my cord collection because I do
believe this is a global crisis and so I
wanted to give you my cord collection
and so I I give you guys this is there
micro USB in there there's there's all
of them okay there's all of them thank
you guys so much for coming we really
appreciate it thank you thank you guys